here
my name is hans and the
ring light is reflecting off my glasses
it's really hard to line it up
but it looks like i am looking through a
scope or something
something cool like that
it's good to be here i'm chilling out
having a good time
uh
wondering if this is doing anything
uh you never know until [ __ ] starts
popping off
uh it'd be nice if i could angle this a
little bit
up
upwards
and onwards
i uh
i'm doing a little show today
at the vulcan
i would say come out but it's probably
already sold out
so there's my head
i am doing good
this will force me to stand up sit up
straight
so that i'm perfectly in frame
maybe even come over here a little bit
um so yeah i mean i'm just ready to talk
you know let's just talk it out and see
what what's going on inside my head i
think that's good
um i think the more that everyone talks
the better it is and i am i want to get
it started
you sound congested
uh oh
i think it's because i ate something
spicy i'm gonna blame it on that i had a
bit of general sews i did not catch a
cold
i'm good
um
i'm doing great right now haven't caught
covered yet you know this is the biggest
spike in kovid since
whenever and uh so far it hasn't got me
i did catch cove at once but
that was a long time ago and now i'm
just coasting on the nocova train
i love not having kovid it's one of my
favorite things
i do love thai food it's one of my
favorite foods is thai food
i think thai food is great
i think that
this is always called phil impropriety
i would love to find out how to
fix things and
you know but whatever
i uh i think it's great
that i don't have covid and think it's
great that i'm not sick i just have a
little runny nose from eating
it runs in the family a lot of people in
my family have runny nose says
stop eating bats in your van
a van bat
thought it rhymed but it didn't
um i'm doing good yesterday i did a
little podcast called kilimus
tanunmis
killed tony
amazing show yesterday can't wait for
you guys to see it comes out in two
weeks
set your watches
it's gonna be great do you trust the
white man does the white man trust
himself
doesn't even look like they trust each
other
uh
the what man
doesn't even trust
another white man and you're asking me
to trust a white man
i ain't gonna trust a white man
till the white man can start trusting
himself
that was offensive to
two races
luckily it wasn't offensive to the
mexicans because they are the second
largest population so i still got them
on my side for this cast
i have two sisters [ __ ]
cusie of david lucas ever roasted you
yeah i mean i think he's called me
autistic a couple times but never really
that intensely
um
[Music]
yeah i'm trying to avoid that for as
much as possible
um
what's a joke you thought would work but
you ditched it because it never worked
feel better i feel fine everyone thinks
i'm sick right now and i'm not sick
there is no loyalty between the white
man
what man don't even love each other
the what man
um what is the joke that i abandoned
huh
well i'm trying to think of some cool
[ __ ] that i thought of in the past
um
fox or focus bro
focus is that a news channel
um so the the thing is that uh
a joke that i abandoned
um i mean i haven't really abandoned any
joke it's just on the back burner until
i can use it again
but i have a joke about communism that i
haven't done in a while
i did not take it personally when
holtzman called me a flat nose to [ __ ]
thanks for asking and also slightly
insulting me
without ever having to
insult me
like someone else said that katan
tonight one can only hope
katan happens when your mind and your
body is one and the universe aligns
katan can never be forced
katan
must be
birthed into the world in a very natural
organic way
um let's go brandon
clap clap clap clap clap clap clap
i knew exactly how to enunciate that and
rhythmically say that
just because i'm part of this culture
and we see things the same way
i don't really know um
what um
what thing that i could do
that i haven't done or that a joke that
i've abandoned
uh some old joke uh this is too hard
is there an online version of katan yeah
there is but it's not the same i usually
play katan for the friendship with the
omicron it's getting kind of dicey when
will you sell your podcast to spotify
i probably want to get more than 14
viewers
do you have any jokes about women's
basketball
yeah
um
women's basketball
i don't remember it maybe that's one of
the jokes that i abandoned
um
i think that uh let's go brandon is
great you know who doesn't want brandon
to do great
um i just feel like if they had an
actual criticism of biden they would
levy that against him instead of just
random catchphrases
but yeah brent let brandon
let's go brandon
um
what an ineffectual
weak olympic
criticism of a politician
um you know
i guess that's the key is to make it
bite-sized and fun to say then we could
have actually elected john kerry instead
of george bush twice
because george bush got us into iraq and
afghanistan
and
you know he was a terrible president who
cheated
the first time
with the supreme court and uh florida
and jeb bush and all that
uh so yeah it's good to be here you know
this is the hans kim podcast slash cast
slash broadcast slash live stream slash
twitch
it's really defies all definition this
is just me talking and there doesn't
have to be an official name to it you
don't have to call it something you can
just do it and that's what i like to do
i just like to talk and uh this is great
because now i can do
double the talking than in a partner
guest podcast i do want guests on this
podcast it just takes a little bit of
planning and foresight and i kind of
like to do this randomly and whenever i
have the time and inclination to do it
so that's sort of how my life has lived
and maybe if i
start living with someone that'd be nice
viceroy needs some advice on his dating
and i would love to give it to you any
specific queries
um yesterday i got freaky
with some lady
i fingered her
and then i came on her
so you could say i'm an expert with the
females
um so yeah i mean something funny that i
noticed is that uh
it's so great to finger someone who's
like
uh not so intellectual and it's like
actually like a human being like
uh someone who's had an unfortunate life
because then they're more in the moment
and it's better because they're just
feeling things and stuff i got a joke
i'm working on do you ever try jokes on
comics like brainstorming or just open
mics i try not to try jokes out before i
do it i just do it on stage and maybe i
should try it out before in conversation
i just don't want to do that i feel like
i feel like it sully's the moment when
i'm actually on stage and saying it i'd
rather just say it
whatever
glass is off
i would rather just say it because i
feel like if i say it
before in a situation that's not comedy
then it ruins it because the comedy
situation is very specific and i don't
want to do it in other situations
and ruin my confidence in the joke or
ruin the timing of it or think of it in
a different way i just want it to be
purely for the stage
um
thank you wyndon carlisle thanks for
coming to the show in houston i had a
great time i hope that people in dallas
will show up to my show there's a show
here in austin as well the creek in the
game on thursday dallas i'm on friday at
dallas comedy club go on their website
your finger smells like apple cider
vinegar and decent childhoods
yeah i mean um i think that uh if you
have someone who's just like so nerdy
and always thinking about sex in a very
intellectual way
um
then it's just a [ __ ] proposition
because they're always like oh my god
i'm having sex right now oh look i'm
feeling pleasure in my genitals this
person is making me feel pleasure in my
genitals wow is this allowed should i be
doing this what does my dad think what
do i think about the social implications
and what do feminists think about this
and what do
the religious clerics have to say about
the position that i'm in right now and
it's just all a bunch of extra noise and
garbage but maybe if our culture was sex
positive uh you could uh think cool
thoughts
and your conscious mind would be uh
filled with awesome distractions when
you're having sex like oh my god i'm
having sex with this person and she's a
part of this community that i live in
that is going to become the next great
thing and we're all going to space and
she's this astronaut and i'm [ __ ]
this astronaut
and
she's going to go to space soon and
i'm going to have my [ __ ] in her so i'm
going to sort of go into space
and
i'm filling her up with good feelings
and she's going to be an astronaut she's
going to contribute to the furtherance
of our species and intelligent life
she's a researcher she's
making dolphins speak
so if that was like what was going on
your head maybe you could have like a
super you know planetary galactic orgasm
uh but unfortunately right now it's like
oh my god she's probably on tick tock
you know she's uh probably gonna go eat
fast food after this like our culture
isn't very rich and like
how we
value and treasure humans so it's hard
to
you know uh
consciously
be in the moment
instead it's better to be an animal and
not think about you know two for one
specials at arby's or the toyotathon
so it's just uh it's just better to have
sex in a culture that's like actually
doing something
rather than just stagnating and buying
things and
coming up with new flavors of mountain
dew
so yeah i mean maybe consciously we
should check in and tune in and
have a better society so that we can
have better sex have you ever dated
someone that has an unpleasant odor
disseminating from their nether regions
and so what approach have you taken
the conversational route of action or
action
um let's say that in this hypothetical
scenario that i'm [ __ ] someone who
smell is repugnant i would be like well
i can't go down on you but i can have
sex with you and if i can have sex with
them i'd be like actually
i'm quite busy today and there's a
meeting and also the bulls are playing
so brb and then just do that and not
have sex with them
um i would say if there's unpleasant
odors disseminating then just don't have
sex with them
that's a good strategy um you know you
should only have sex with people that
you're physically attracted to or
emotionally or socially attracted to
and if that social attraction and
emotional attraction overpowers the
smell then uh you're good to go and
ready to [ __ ] do whatever
um so
gary faust tagged me in a thing
so i'm just going to accept
a review
except
um
yeah hopefully he didn't edit it i
already edited it
um but yeah i i was on kill tony making
fun of gary faust because he's like so
crazy
um
then just be like uh my dick is hurting
and i can't have sex
and fast food to be honest actually
avoid it
actively avoid it
already that would make it much easier
plug your nose and pump like it's stormy
under you
um
i think that china is and has been
planning to take over and it started
with covet this is a fact
i mean i don't know if china
did this on purpose
i don't think that they could have
predicted we would have responded so
poorly
maybe they engineered it so amazingly
that it spread like crazy
um
china i don't think that they needed
this pandemic to take over i think it
would have happened inevitably
um but the pandemic sure helped
um
[Music]
i think it's great that uh china is out
there you know motivating us to get our
[ __ ] together because we can't just
constantly be fighting each other
um but yeah china
we should all
try to be better than china
if china is better than us that just
means we're not trying
um
and we're
not so i think that
uh
as a country we could do better but i
think as a species we should do better
and we should have more special pride
um
and as a life on earth maybe we could
have earth pride
um i mean we failed as a government not
as people but who controls the
government
corporations
i mean the government we should control
it the government the concept of
governments are not bad it's just the
fact that money buys governments
what's the pettiest reason you stopped
going out with a lady mine was when she
wouldn't shave her bush after she said
she would and had acquired all the
accoutrements united states and china on
the same team behind the scenes
yeah it's all about money
since america is ruled by money uh it's
easy to hack into america and we need to
be ruled over by something deeper than
money because uh then it becomes easy to
lead us astray and [ __ ] us up um
is america deed
not yet
let's talk about this play call of duty
is it has something at least to do with
hong kong
hong kong is a great city uh they
apparently didn't want to become a part
of china and they had a lot of protests
about it which i thought were cool i
love watching protests because of the
people
doing some crazy [ __ ]
um but
um
[Music]
yeah when
ever
you have your friend's place to watch
you can podcast
yeah that's pretty much what i do i mean
i do it in the van too
um so something comedic is that
the homeless problem exists and people
want to get them
to do menial tasks to give them basic
human rights but i think we should just
give them basic human rights and hope
that they get their [ __ ] together
if you're a legit call me you would
agree to help me out on my comedy spec
i mean you should do your work and get
paid fairly for your work
uh hans gonna hit that margaret chocho
uh margaret cho is actually in face off
um
can i rent your van oh i'm just gonna
hear that
those protests are happening than the
virus coincidence i think not
i mean you could draw together
conclusions from two desperate events or
you could just like
you know
admit that some of what you held dear
and true to your heart might not be true
like
american exceptionalism or
that making rich people richer is better
for the world if you choose which retail
store would you target for a flash mob
robbery probably like
um
if exxon valdez had a store
or fannie mae or freddie mac or whatever
those [ __ ] whatever
i mean i could plug my
podcast on the
kill tony podcast but that's not really
what kill tony is for it's not like an
advertisement space
i mean it is for that short little time
that they have where they do
advertisements but i'm not gonna go and
kill tony
to boost my numbers i mean i'm gonna do
that
happenstantially
i'm gonna go and kill tony
to do kill tony answer questions be
funny hopefully
talk about my dick talk about
you know
getting a lot of action
hopefully you know
racism
tacos eating good stuff i mean i don't
really
if if killed tony helps me with my pot i
don't have to get the most amount of
juice out of kill tony like oh i'm going
to go there plug my podcast plug my
shows the fact that i'm on there is
already plugging my podcast on my shows
so anything extra that comes from that
is is great
i just want to go and kill tony to
actually do kill tony i don't really
give a [ __ ] about
advertisements
and doing all that because that happens
naturally and i just have to be mean i'd
rather try to be funny than try to get
as much advertisements on there as
possible
um
and you can give the podcast a shout out
i mean i did come up with a couple jokes
on the podcast like my joke about asian
eyes and how they're small so that we
can have an extra layer of skin over our
eyeballs to
insulate it
[Music]
um game was a great show squid games
squid game there was only one squid game
that had multiple games within it
um the idea that rich people would get
off on watching poor people fight to the
death
i think is unrealistic because poor
people fighting to the death is not that
entertaining
um maybe people
um
maybe people [ __ ] you know whatever
maybe people [ __ ] can relate to that
or some [ __ ] maybe they could be like oh
man that that person fighting has a
human face or something
um so yeah i mean i think that um
squid games could happen in real life
if you
made it entertaining but ufc took
forever to take off
so it would take a while for squid games
to take off
and
until it took off you'd be wasting a lot
of money building an audience
[Music]
i just think that
it's great to have a show about that
because if money rules everything then
the people with the money rule
everything and whatever they want to do
is gonna happen and if they want to
watch people struggle and fight to the
death then there's nothing that can stop
them from getting that we can't stop
them from getting that in a world that's
ruled by money
but
if we are ruled by the
uh
goals and dreams of our species and we
can
have a higher ideal than just whatever
makes most money in the short term then
we would stop squid games to be like
this is not in line with our goals and
ideals
we are striving for higher
things and we would stop squid games
but since everything is about
uh whatever the rich people want and
their amusement because they already
have everything then
it's just gonna be
a shitty shitty world and we should try
to do better than that and it's easy to
do it and we should do it
[Music]
so any advice for people who are moving
to austin to pursue comedy so this is my
advice to you if you're moving to austin
to pursue comedy
don't do open mics just wait for joe
rogan to text you and then open up for
him
um
that's sort of what i'm doing so i don't
know if that's good advice
uh here's my advice if you're moving to
austin to do comedy just write a lot of
funny funny jokes the funnier the jokes
are the funnier you'll be and the better
that you'll be at uh
comedy in
austin
if you don't have funny jokes then it's
gonna be really really hard in austin
you're gonna end up like some loser who
only lives in a van and farts around all
over new york city
um
i mean what i did was i did a bunch of
open mics and wrote for eight years of
my life and then i got lucky in new york
i mean i was pretty successful in
seattle too
uh and i've only been doing it a couple
years since then so i
mean i would say if you're moving to
austin to do comedy step number one is
try to have as few jobs as possible try
to work as little as possible and try to
do jobs that will actually make you
better as a person like the job that i
chose to do was to build my van out and
make it an awesome van the less time
that you're doing [ __ ] that has no
effect on you and isn't really helpful
the better you don't want to just waste
your time making money for someone else
if you are enriched and you need
to
have uh
[Music]
to do menial tasks to find meaning and
to enrich yourself as a person
then
just [ __ ] dig a ditch by yourself
don't let someone else tell you to dig a
ditch you know at least do something
useful for yourself don't just be
exploited and have your work go to
someone else do work for yourself if
that's what you need you just need a
discipline would you rather have the
the discipline to force yourself to work
or would you rather discipline to wake
up at the same time every morning to go
30 minutes
somewhere else and work or you could
just force yourself to do it here all
that energy that you took that you're
gonna take to travel to somewhere else
and listen to someone else tell you what
to do just use that in your own head and
just do whatever the [ __ ] you need to do
uh you know build a nice cardboard hut
on the middle of 6th street
um
can i call you
oh my god can you even imagine if i
called joe rogan right now
that would be
crazy for no [ __ ] reason other than
you people
wanting me to do it
oh my god i would never
never do that for you
[ __ ]
joe rogan's mine i will keep him all to
myself
no i wouldn't betray joe rogan's trust
with his numeros
to [ __ ]
exploit it to get five more viewers on
my podcast
that isn't even monetized right now it
will be later after i figure it out
but uh yeah i mean i would never betray
joe rogan's trust i love joe rogan and i
will do anything he asks
um
um stream analytics discord filtering
about i don't know how to do any of this
um
what am i on right now i'm on general
sauce chicken and gordito
gordita chicken wrap
um and
water a lot of water
um
do you get paid for being
an awesome person
yeah dude
everyone just gives me money just
because i'm awesome
um
yeah uh
why is everyone on joe rogan's dick
because he's one of the most famous
successful broadcasters media figures
influencers uh
you know podcasters in the world and he
did it all by himself with no outside
influences he's completely free
from the selfishness and inequities of
our system
he is a self-made man and he is a proof
for the american dream even though you
have to be a crazy crazy rich
successful disciplined amazing person to
do it he is
what america has produced
and he's an amazing uh
person who um
you know he is our only hope to fight up
against the big corporations
he has enough money as a corporation
but he can fight he has the right
motivations and the right
uh you know he's he's uh he's [ __ ]
god he's uh
got it he's um
his motivations are pure
you know like if exxon valdez started
polluting ladybird lake here in austin
he would be on it he'd be like
let's not do this
these [ __ ] are [ __ ] with the
thing and it's polluting
when everyone else cnn fox news
msnbc you pay them enough money they'll
say whatever you want but not joe rogan
joe rogan would fight for the people
he's got the best interest of the people
in mind he has no other influences he is
paid directly by us
the people
so he is our champion
he is uh
the
the answer to corporatism
he's one of the people he's a worker
and
there's a secret secret out there that
uh there might be a little comedy club
opening up in austin sometime soon
and it's gonna be [ __ ] dope
and that's another reason why joe rogan
is awesome
but uh
yeah i mean i love joe rogan he's a
reason why i started comedy he was a
role model to me
and the dad that everyone wanted exactly
uh he
supplied a
path through
the jungles of our country and this
world
and he just told us that if we work hard
and get better that we can do it
we are the key to taking them down joe
rogan is a big name store now dude he's
a store
let me go buy something because
he's a store
he has sold out to spotify he no longer
has comic song getting baked in swearing
it's all bs
polo ticks now
um yeah i mean i don't think he's sold
out he says whatever he wants i have not
gotten joe rogan elk
um i don't think open mics let 16 year
olds
yeah i mean if you're 16 years old it's
hard but you just got to sneak in where
you can sneak in you know it's hard i
think it's a very weird system that we
have where we don't let children
intermingle with adults and so they can
never become adults until they're too
old and they're boring anyways
and it cuts off the talent of 16 year
old 17 18 19 20 year old comedians
who can uh practice their skill and
develop their talent and now they just
can't so that's sad
but the good news is that
once you hit 21 the world is your oyster
and you could find other places and you
can just write more and practice
um
so yeah i mean
what else is going on you know
bob saget died he was a great comedian
filthy
filthy comedian who was uh
on tv in america in the most wholesome
roles as a sitcom dad and as america's
funniest videos host and it just shows
that the ideal image of a person that we
thought in the 90s and
80s is unrealistic
it's not
it's not sustainable and you need that
dark side that dark underbelly to give
you meaning and to be a real person and
bob saget found a role
and he uh did very well at it
um
but yeah i mean
we're becoming older everyone's becoming
older and um
we know more celebrities now than ever
before i mean imagine 60 years from now
when all the celebrities that we know
are gonna die we just have so many more
we got logan paul we got tila tequila we
got [ __ ] you know people on tik tok
and instagram
uh you know like
bjj stars and uh you know chess
prodigies we just know so many more
people now so we're just gonna have to
get used to people dying and hopefully
not freak out every time it happens
but uh yeah it's just uh
it's just uh
it's just a fact of life and it's uh
difficult but uh yeah i mean uh
we are getting older and we are
um gonna have more dead people and
it's just like it's sad because once
people are gone they're forever gone and
you can't get them back even for a
minute just to say goodbye
um
but
yeah i mean it sucks
um bob saget died
um
stay tuned i'm gonna have merch soon i
got t-shirts i actually ordered t-shirts
to the vulcan
and apparently someone stole it or
something but i went missing and then i
messaged underground printing
uh in michigan or minnesota or something
and um
they sent me a whole new box for free so
they basically lost money
and uh i still got it
and so that's sweet an awesome great
customer service way to take one for the
team
i just said the ups
didn't
deliver it or it's not here and they
just sent me a new one so i didn't even
have insurance or anything on it they
just sent it to me
so
well what a great company underground
printing so this is an advertisement for
them ah they deserve it
uh so if i can do an advertisement for a
company that did something nice for me
and save me 500 bucks then i can do a
podcast an advertisement for a person
who is really nice to me sam kuiper
very nice to me he's been on the catan
lives
i think once or twice
he uh self selflessly
uh does the camera work for other people
comedy so if you like the zoom ins and
the you know pants then thank sam kuiper
he's doing it and he's uh just out of
the goodness of his heart what a nice
little guy he is
um
it's not free oh
yeah now we all know how to get free
merch thanks hans
i'm brad is now gonna stake out at the
vulcan and try to steal all my merch
uh but i learned my lesson i'm not gonna
send it to the vulcan again because
apparently you can't send mail to the
vulcan
um
so yeah i mean
apparently you can't get mail sent to
the vulcan what the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] is this not america you don't
have a system for getting mails or
packages you just it just gets stolen
like you should figure something out so
you can get packages in america on the
street in a public place like you just
you're just not gonna have a place for
that like maybe you should figure out a
way with this postal system to be like
hey i'm going to deliver a package you
want to make sure that it gets received
but yeah apparently it's just like
whatever we're not going to think about
it i did my job you do your job type of
deal so it's like why don't we plan and
figure it out together
usually you send it where you live lol
yeah i mean i could have sent it here
i should have i think i get mail
delivered to the door here i was just
worried i don't know how the mail works
here so i didn't want to do it
i should get a kettlebell here that
would be nice i might get ripped but i
should just do a lot of push-ups or
something
um yeah
send it to the van i'm parked on
zilker park uh right next to the tree
the big tree with the yellow bird in it
um next to a red car so just deliver it
that's that's the address
po box bruh how much is a p.o box bruh
and if i can save that money why
wouldn't i
why wouldn't i just get it sent to a
friend a friend is like a p.o box that
delivers to you at the open mic that
you're going to
so
what is advantage of a po box if i have
friends
[Music]
if only the post office has sort of box
you can pay for a service to receive
deliveries to how does the vulcan
receive deliveries you just can't
receive deliveries if you're on sixth
street like if you're a modern business
on in the world then you should [ __ ]
be able to accept packages and not just
get it stolen right in front of your
door
um
i think that it's funny that a lot of
comedians are like it's just a joke man
why can't you take a joke
but every joke is saying something and
what you're saying should be trying to
be something correct and good and
instead of spreading
badness and sadness in the world like i
have a joke about mission trips and
africa
and i just think it's funny to
make fun of africans and how they have
aids
and i think that uh it's not a bad joke
because it's
just funny to say african people have
aids
[Music]
but
[Music]
you need to lift the heavyweight being
self-sufficient is good
you will never be mitch head hedberg
head spelled h-e-a-d
hedberg
um but yeah i mean uh i think that is a
light jab and that it is easily
dismissible
because
um
if you think all african people have
aids then it's not a very rich
view of the world
and i think that um it's just like
[Music]
that uh
um yeah i don't know i think it's fine
i don't uh feel bad saying it but yeah i
mean it's like uh
it's just a playful jab and i think that
uh
i respect african people
and that's why i can make fun of them is
because i know that they are amazing and
good at stuff
but uh yeah i mean uh
i think that uh it's important that if
you're saying things like african people
have aids that
people know that um
that's not all that you think about
african people if it's like clearly a
one-sided thing then it's like oh
there's no way you could function in
life
thinking that about
african people so it's like
wouldn't it be funny if that was the
case
and then that by
illuminating something negative
you illuminate a larger and more complex
picture of that race or people
but uh yeah i mean i like doing it i
don't feel like it's hurting african
people in general so
sorry i'm gonna continue to do it
hans have you ever been to south korea
yeah multiple times i'm south korean
myself probably
south
southwest korean
is one right really retiring after this
here
i mean
i don't know it's up to him he uh says
that he wants to i heard his podcast
with joe rogan how often do you write
jokes i try to write jokes every day
my process is that i wake up i brush my
teeth i jerk off and then i lay back in
bed i have a little bluetooth keyboard i
lay down and i try to write 2 000 words
every day
um
and then
[Music]
write 2 thousand words
and then throughout the day if anything
comes up it's easier for me to write
down whatever is in my head because i
just practiced writing 2 000 words of
whatever was in my head
onto my phone on my keyboard so now that
i have practice writing down my head
thoughts into making it digital words
the process of writing jokes becomes
easier whenever a brilliant brilliant
joke comes into my head
as is often the case
the the brilliance is just flowing
through me every day i come up with a
new joke about tacos or some [ __ ] but
yeah i mean it's been a while and i hope
that i can write a bunch of new jokes
and i'm kind of worried because i've
been going through a dry spell but every
day i write whatever it is in my head
even if it's [ __ ] it's all gonna
come out um
yeah i mean
there's gonna be a bottom rung to our
society there's gonna be a lower class
of people that are struggling and it's
just how far of a basement do you want
in our society do you want the basement
of our society to be
total
destitution and poverty and sadness or
do you want it to be
the lower class and the bottom rung of
our society to be well fed and housed
and still functional and being able to
do menial tasks or whatever tasks that
they're capable of and also be able to
rehabilitate themselves to not be
destitute
and at the lowest rung of society do you
want to have a lowest rung of our
society that is just a bungee pit that's
death and you can never get out or do
you want to be able to have a society
where you can dip and fall and hit rock
bottom and then bounce back up like all
the most interesting most successful
people have done do you want to live in
a world with no miss pat or would you
rather have a world where people can
live difficult lives and come back from
it and it's like you can be like well
they're all drug addicts they're all sad
they're lonely they're boring they're
stupid but there's always going to be a
lowest wrong it's just that our lowest
rung in our society is a very very sad
desperate place but that place could be
improved and not so
needlessly
uh
torturous and that would make everyone
else better and also people don't like
to be threatened and if you have a
society that's like
do good or else you're going to be out
in the streets then it
doesn't breed
uh repres
reciprocity it does breed reciprocity in
a negative direction and it doesn't
breed reciprocity in a good
good positive direction
um yeah i mean
that's just what i think and uh i think
that
we need to improve society because
it's just very very very sad that
so many people are suffering
and uh yeah i just like to think about
things restructuring sustainable
agriculture and offset the dependency
earning more time for the people to work
on themselves
if you had to sacrifice one of them
between tony and joe who are you
choosing jesus christ i don't like to
play these hypothetical games um i feel
like that they are
a waste of time
uh i think that choosing between two
amazing people who have helped me a lot
is
unnecessary
and
you know
yeah
how do you feel about universal basic
income
i think it's good
i love universal basic income we need a
basic income we need to help people and
give them more money
uh we should just take it from the right
people
um
universal basic income i think it would
be nice
[Music]
um
i just don't think that it's sustainable
or something
oops wrong way
can we talk about movies rather than
politics
i mean
it's just weird that people don't want
to talk about politics
it's just
like
who doesn't want to hear about politics
it's like so fun to talk about real [ __ ]
and then to put a little bit of comedy
on it i'd rather do that than have like
all joking and fart noises and unicorns
and then
a little bit of reality
yeah well you know scotsky if you uh
want to do a little thing then you can
do it but
this is what i like talking about this
is what i talk about all the time
yeah what should you be getting done
peter jenkins how are your children
doing maybe your bills need to get paid
or you have some debt that needs to uh
be
paid off
but that's what i find comedy in is the
misery and the sadness politic political
talk leads to nothing being resolved so
not talking about politics leads to
things being resolved just feeling good
about yourself just
butts and
farts and mexican food
um have you ever had a pregnancy scare
nope
you have to have a lot of sex for that
and that doesn't really
happen a lot for me
uh
do you listen to breaking points i don't
know what that is yes please destroy me
um like my life i think is very sad
sometimes so
seattle people want political talk 24 7.
i would love to have kids i think kids
are great because they're little
honesty machines and they just honestly
look at the world and they have human
intelligence and they have human verbal
skills and it's just cool to have a
little thing that can observe the world
it's like if your toaster could talk
kids are like an object that has the
ability to talk back to you so
yeah kids are great
uh
who's your favorite korean american
probably john cho i think he's handsome
and he's a good actor and he's korean
um another great korean american is
chloe kim from the olympics a
snowboarder
she's the modern whatever
all i've heard is bickering about
politics but no solutions
well look who's the one talking about
politics now i was just talking about
korean americans but you want to talk
about how we shouldn't talk about
politics that's a little political don't
you think
um
thoughts on kryto
kryto is great uh i'm more a fan of
cronum cronenberg
or um cro crow
magnum macronus
cyclops
um i think that
uh we avoid politics
and i think that's sad
because i think politics is so fun
because it's real and people's real
feelings get involved
and you can actually delve into what
people are actually feeling and thinking
instead of just talking about things
that don't matter anyone can talk about
things that don't matter
uh but i'd rather talk about real things
and just [ __ ] see what people
actually think and feel and you know if
we all think and feel
a certain way we can change the world
and i think that is uh
that is what is awesome there was like
some
paragraph or an essay where like
why do you talk about rich people rich
people don't care about what you think
and this guy was like
as a matter of fact
the only thing rich people care about is
what you think they don't care about
you know whatever whatever they care
about you
overthrowing the wealth distribution
that we have right now and what we think
is the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that can
overthrow them like look at technology
all the rich people wanted to keep all
that wealth and keep it to themselves
but with technology we were like oh look
shiny little screens and tvs and we
started buying it and then we created
bill gates and elon musk and jeff bezos
who are now the richest people in the
world that we know of
and uh it's just like once the people
have decided to buy something there's
nothing you can do the people are the
power
we are the species the one or two rich
people that lord over us
only reward over us economically and
through machinations of the economy but
um
we have the power
we are the species we are the future and
as long as uh you're [ __ ] uh
thinking about
um
[Music]
you know humanity
it's gonna be awesome
um
okay so
i think that uh
i thought you said yesterday every video
was strong as far as that new material
your set yesterday video i thought your
set yesterday video was strong as [ __ ]
was that new material your set yesterday
video you mean i'll kill tony
um what did i talk about circumcision is
old confederate flag is old
and character late is old as all old
material
but yeah i got some fire news stuff i
just don't want to reveal it right away
because uh
because um
i want it to be perfect when i reveal it
on kill tony because i can't do it again
and i've done a couple bits where i'm
like damn i couldn't deliver that better
and i feel regret so i don't want to do
bits until i'm ready to solidify them
and to kill tony and luckily i have a
wealth of old material to delve into
and i think a lot of it is good it's
just like weird how i didn't say it
already because whatever reason
um but yeah i mean hopefully my level of
uh skill and my
jokes
my quality of jokes
maintains
but uh yeah i mean
it's gonna be hard but i
love that i got this regular spot on
kill tony because
i've uh i've been doing comedy for
however whatever and uh it's just i've
been writing jokes forever so
i have jokes that have only worked in
the short amount of time that i wrote
them and now i get to have a way to
solidify that and keep it in concrete
for the rest of
eternity
and i think that this is a great
opportunity to capture what i do and
what i write and
the beauty of the comedy experience is
very fleeting and unless you capture
that it could go away and this is like
the perfect avenue for me to capture
these fleeting jokes that i have
and i'm really excited
about it
um yeah i mean i think that uh
i'm excited to do these jokes and i
think that it's great to capture what
the joke writing process is like and how
open mics have been for me as a tool
so
yeah i'm really excited about this kill
tony opportunity
and uh
i'm just laying down the
foundation for
the [ __ ] that's coming up because i'm
excited to show off the new new stuff
it's just
i'm i'm easing it in there
i'm all for redistributing the wealth
but i don't think
but i don't understand how you think
communism would work work needs to be
incentivized somehow or people don't
want to do anything just human nature
the human nature argument
um i don't think that a lot of americans
have a good understanding of how
communism would work because they have
been propagandized to like the red scare
like why do you think that we would have
any idea of what communism is
when we've been at a all-out war against
it
since the beginning of its creation like
obviously we're gonna have a wrong take
on it because we've been [ __ ]
told
to hate it so
first of all
we're biased as americans to hate
communism
so
you got to take anything that
that has
been a
idea planted in your head with a grain
of salt
and i don't think that
we need to be motivated by selfish greed
or
accumulation of mansions like in america
in this 50s or 60s malcolm gladwell
tells a story about how
this uh
ceo helped the american government with
this big project
and all they he got was from it was
a note from uh
the secretary general or whatever and
he's like he framed it he's like this is
all the reward that i need to know that
i did good for america and that was
motivation and enough for him
to do uh good work
i think that there's a lot of aspects to
human nature it's not just the selfish
greed and
short-term profits and self-interest
that motivates us we're motivated by a
lot of different things we just are in a
current state of humanity where we're
motivated by
selfish greed and accumulation of bling
bling and
uh
nice
a nice fit and a lamborghini murcielago
and i think that there's a lot of
different cultures in the world and that
we can choose a culture that we want
and
and i think that we chose this one
and that there's
there's the obvious consequences of it
which is the destruction of the planet
and are the devaluation of other human
beings
um
but there's a lot of different other
areas of human nature we can tap into
work needs to be incentivized i mean
look at teachers working for minimum
wage who still do good work and
work for their kids or nurses who are
not even getting hazard pay who are at
hospitals right now taking care of sick
republicans
who are dying to own the libs
there's a lot of different ways to
incentivize people to work and it's not
like capitalism does a great job of
incentivizing people to work
they get paid minimum wage to work
workers have no rights in america we
don't even get health care
and we still work our asses off we get
no sick days we get no maternity leave
and people are still in a fast food jobs
working their ass off
[Music]
and
you know what is the motivation in
america to work to
be one of the upper rich class well we
have the 27th best social mobility in
the world so it's not even a reality for
most of us
and it's been uh designed that way on
purpose to preserve the current wealth
distribution
um
and uh i don't think that capitalism
incentivizes us to work because
it incentivizes us to earn money
and to cheat to get ahead but it doesn't
necessarily incentivize us to work if
you work
it's not as surefire way of gaining
success it's just a way of
[Music]
of getting cheated out of your time and
energy
and look at what capitalism produces we
don't care about innovation or creating
new inventions we don't
create new [ __ ] we create
slightly different versions of old
iphones or like a remake of spider-man
again
it's not
the creativity that we're looking for
we're looking for profit at all costs
and i don't think that drives innovation
um
where did you get your philosophy degree
i got it from the university of
listening to hassan [ __ ] are you trying
to be the korean lex friedman
doc
[Music]
uh someone's coming to this
communist china chiefs to get ahead too
uh yeah
i first have sex with my uncle he's just
stronger than me
uh yeah that sucks
um china is what america uses to be
vice versa
um communism would work with a lot of
nice
working togetherness and voting
and uh people just being like hey you
should be in charge of uh
you should be in charge of inventing new
[ __ ] and you should be in charge of uh
picking a direction for the company and
then they would get a percentage of the
profit and the workers would get a
percentage of the profit instead of
giving workers just minimum wage and
stockholders
um
[Music]
stockholders getting a percentage of the
profit
i definitely feel more american
moved to china then china is a horrible
country america is where all the loot is
stored i'd rather stay here and suck up
all that loot
uh
i uh
they should be in charge of a camp
uh i love korea korea is a great place i
just think that korea is
a
is a a beautiful country i mean they
have a lot of old wisdom that's trapped
inside of korea
that's hard to translate
and it's just trapped in korean and
unless you understand korea and their
culture you don't understand their
deep wealth of wisdom and
whatever
and i think it's sad i think we should
be able to talk to each other and
understand each other's culture and i
think that'd be a better world
on um running around cost worker owned
co-ops
worker owned co-ops are nice
um i mean i think there is a role of a
ceo i just don't think that he should
take as much money as he does in our
current system
um
if the pie was fixed it wouldn't be
possible to create new value and grow
the pie take a shitty car fix it up and
sell and capture profits from a newfound
value what's wrong with that
yeah you should fix cars what is this an
argument for mechanics
um yeah fix and sell new cars and make
it better cars and just create awesome
cars
planned obsolescence
hans do you have white guilt yeah i do
have white girl i feel very white that's
why i like to [ __ ] on white people as a
white person myself
i think that white people
should be [ __ ] on a lot because we have
a lot of
wealth and
leisure and luxury so we're the ones
that can take it as a white man
i say go at it go hard on white people
who else are you going to make fun of
everyone else is suffering asian people
asian people are so sensitive right now
because they've been being shoved into
subway tracks
by black people so we're just like
really sad right now
because we've been building railroads
and because of uh you know
world war ii we're very very sensitive
but uh yeah i mean if you're gonna make
fun of anyone i would say white people
this is your role this is the white
man's burden you know you get all the uh
colonialism loot but then you just
just have to be made fun of a little bit
i would say that's a good trade-off i'd
much rather be white than
mexican or black that would suck
but they have rich cultures it's just
like economically some of them are
struggling and
um but yeah i mean black people what an
amazing race
they suffered quite a lot but produced
the most amazing music
and art
and uh athleticism
they are they're quite spectacular
wonderful wonderful people who are
wonderfully wonderfully talented and
don't know if that was racist
but black people have done amazing [ __ ]
um
howdy from brooklyn i'll be in brooklyn
soon
please please contact me
your eyes evolve like that my eyes
evolved like that to warm my eyes up
from the cold goby desert
it's very very warm eyes i can warm my
eyes really quickly while your eyes
would freeze
thoughts on the jews the jews were in a
very unique position in
europe where they were a minority and
they had to
scramble and survive and they took jobs
that the white man didn't like usury and
debt and so they gained a little place
in society
doing jobs that were deemed unseemly by
the
racial majority and then turns out those
jobs were [ __ ] awesome like banking
turns out banking is [ __ ] dope
uh and white people just gave it to the
jews because they were like that's gross
no one wants to do that no one wants to
be in charge of
getting back alone
so they gave it to the jews and they
were a racial minority that
occupied a little tiny role in european
society that turned out to be very
successful and lucrative
and really
they
white people kind of
you know
help them and and that role but you we
all need jews you know
if you're running a society you need
like a racial minority to do your dirty
work and that's
that's the role that jews are occupied
in europe
uh you know the role is occupied by
different races in different countries
and vietnam is occupied by the chinese
so it's just like that's that's their
role and then it's easy to hate on them
and to once in a while just be like what
the [ __ ] why are there jews running all
their moneys and [ __ ] and to just
completely like get rid of that
horrible genocide but um
yeah i mean it's a tough tough road to
hoe you got to be wily and smart
you got to think your way out of a
genocide
um but yeah i mean uh
the jews
they're like gypsies but more
acceptable in polite society
[Music]
do i like chinese peoples
let me tell you about the chinese the
chinese
they not good people
they always eating bats and
farting on dogs
i think china is an amazing country if
you read the histories like i have like
i have studied the histories of the
chinese you learned that marco polo was
lair king
you learned that they built the wall so
that they could uh have slinky contests
i don't know that much about china but
the thing about china is that they
dominated asia and they were the
cultural influence of that region and
the way that america is now to much of
the world
and if you go to asia i mean korean all
the signs in korea were in chinese until
pretty recently
japan all the architecture in japan and
korea influenced by china they were a
hegemonic power and they were
very very wise and the only reason we
don't look at them at the same way as
the romans or the greeks
is because
they didn't end up conquering [ __ ]
they just stayed inside and started
fighting each other and
[ __ ]
cultural revolutionizing each other
but yeah china is a great place
uh
you're don't pick up the soap dough
that's right free in my head
nice
that's good
it's a good joke
uh but yeah china is a good place japan
was like a little island where they were
all fighting each other just being
violent and angry and just farting all
over each other
um
yeah but i have to go open up for
joe rogan
so thank you guys so much